okay let's go next to our caller from
the eight four three area code who's
calling today from eight four three
hey this is Chris Murphy hey Chris I
haven't been to Myrtle Beach since I was
like 13 is it still the same I guess
yes same girl grew up down here
but um yeah my question for you today is
I proceed my question today is which kid
of all the candidates you think would be
the most likely to defeat Trump in 2020
I don't have any personal opinion on
this beyond what the polls say the polls
say that Biden would do well against
Trump it sounds weird to me like I don't
know he's just very low-energy
I don't know how he would deal with
Trump's attacks the polls say Biden
would do well Bernie would do well I
think what like right now it's looking
okay for all of them based on the polls
I don't feel like I need a special
insight into it yeah I like the girl
from California but um I'm thinking that
Biden probably is the best chance right
now I feel like oh you mean Carla Harris
so what you mean Camilla Harris from
California yeah okay the girl from
California okay maybe a little
condescending but yeah I know you I know
you me yes yes but yeah my um it buttons
pretty cool but um you know is this my
question and what part of the party do
you think will be pivotal in showing up
for the vote as far as like people show
me now it was like who do I think is
most reliably going to show up or who if
they felt that would be most beneficial
to the Democratic Party yeah okay I mean
I think the people who are going to show
the people that are going to show up are
the center-left older Democrats they
always vote okay I mean just history we
know the data they always vote so they
are going to vote they are more in favor
of Biden the X Factor is going to be
does the young progressive wing show up
when Trump was elected it was like huge
activism a ton of people activated new
people in politics will their enthusiasm
from two years ago carry through to
where they actually go and vote in
November of 2020 I don't know that's
always the question
guys yeah but yeah appreciate you taking
my call all right Christopher Myrtle
Beach appreciate it I hope the water is
warm down there and all that stuff let's
take a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up I'll get back to the
phones right after the break don't hang
up if you're holding new thing make sure
you're following me on twitch at twitch
TV slash David Pakman I'll be right back
after this